there's honestly nothing more satisfying
than a good poop on the flip side a bad
poop
can ruin your day you know what i'm
talking about
too hard too soft too sudden not soon
enough
if this isn't ringing any bells congrats
on being the world's
only perfect pooper a title to wear with
pride for the rest of us we have to work
at it
the good news is we have science on our
side
there are a bunch of things we can do to
smooth out the kinks in our digestive
system
and some of them are very literal but
real quick let us introduce you to the
bristol stool scale
a handy dandy chart listing the
different types of poop your body can
make
they range from type 1 hard lumps to
type 7
totally liquid when it comes to number 2
you actually want to be a type 3 or
4 anything before indicates constipation
anything after gets closer to diarrhea
depending on where you land on the scale
there are a number of things you can do
to get that coveted smooth snake
let's start with short-term solutions
mooing like a cow or making a similar
noise if you aren't feeling particularly
bovine can help reduce straining
you'll want to lean forward with your
elbows on your knees while you do it
the idea is to open up your belly and
get yourself in a more efficient pooping
position
you see sitting toilets were designed
all wrong
sitting straight up with your feet
planted on the ground actually makes it
harder to squeeze one out
too much straining and pushing can lead
to hemorrhoids most of all
but sometimes even prolapse thanks to
how our bodies are built
we're better off in a squat it's all in
the gut look at the angle of her rectum
when she stands up
it's bent at about 80 degrees right
where it meets the anal canal
fittingly named the anorectal angle sort
of like kinking a hose this bend helps
you control your bowels
along with the muscles in the same area
when you sit that angle unfolds to about
100 degrees
and squatting opens it even further
opening up that pathway makes it easier
for stuff to slide on through
but even though our porcelain thrones
aren't suited for squatting
there are ways to adapt you can throw
your feet up on a stool or even just a
couple rolls of toilet paper
or the dedicated can buy a product
specifically made for this purpose
like the squatty potty or nature's
platform one study followed over
50 healthy poopers through 1 000
collective bowel movements using the
squatty body
the experiment started with a two week
control period of unassisted pooping
then participants spent another two
weeks using the squatty potty ninety
percent of the participants strained
less
and over seventy percent spent less time
on the toilet speaking of
we are very sorry but put down your
phone even you
person who's watching this on the can
right now taking your phone or a book to
the bathroom just encourages you to stay
in there longer
which again leads back to straining and
putting excess pressure on your rectum
and anus
getting up off the toilet can help you
in more ways than one
generally the more you move the more you
poop
exercising can jostle around your
innards helping
shake up food gas and waste to move
through your system
that means less time for your lower
intestine to absorb water from your
stool
and wet soft poops are easier to pass so
going for a quick jog could be helpful
if you're constipated
not so much if you have diarrhea what
you eat can also help
yep we're talking fiber fiber is helpful
no matter which end of the stool scale
you're on
but not all fiber is created equal there
are actually two main types
soluble and insoluble soluble fiber
dissolves in water
turning gooey and spongy it comes from
things like fruit flesh
root vegetables and cooked grains this
stuff takes its time sliding through
your digestive tract
which helps regulate movements you want
to start introducing this type of fiber
to your diet
if you're hovering around a type 6 or 7.
insoluble fiber on the other hand
mostly keeps its shape when wet this
fiber from fruit skins leafy greens and
the outer layer of most whole grains
adds to the bulk of the stool it puts
pressure on your colon walls and
stimulates movement
so this is what you're looking for to
fix a type one or two
but you don't want to load up on either
fiber all at once
first you want to suss out if fiber is
really your issue at all
if you normally get plenty of insoluble
fiber but you're still constipated then
more probably isn't going to help
and too much fiber too quickly can make
you bloated or gassy
when in doubt go see your doctor they
might recommend probiotics which can
help reduce bloating and gas as well as
constipation
when you first start taking them you
might end up in type 6 or 7 territory
for a few days
but that should go away and if adding
stuff to your diet doesn't help maybe
try taking stuff away
dairy caffeine meats spicy foods
alcohol grease certain fruits and
artificial sweeteners
have all been known to cause diarrhea
cutting all or some of that stuff
could help relieve those bowel control
issues
keeping a food diary to find connections
between snacks and symptoms
is also recommended and that way you
don't have to give up on all the good
stuff
at once if you're not the world's only
perfect pooper
taking the perfect poop isn't always
easy
but it should never be as hard as a type
one
with these tips and tricks in your back
pocket you are well on your way to
the throne now go eat drink and jog your
way to the
best poop of your life you earned it
champ
everybody deserves a perfect poo but
always make sure to check with your
doctor before you make significant
changes to your diet or lifestyle
but you could probably move all you want
without a doctor's note
and subscribe below if you want more
ways to optimize your life with science